après un an de guerre il ne reste plus
grand chose de la ville à Liman dans la
région du Dombas 90% des habitations ont
été détruites
même si la ligne de front est plus à
l'est les obus ne cessent de tomber sur
la ville Natalia est l'une des rares
habitantes dont la maison est restée
intacte jusqu'à présent nous avons eu la
chance dans notre appartement seul les
fenêtres ont été soufflées et
destructions sont minimes il est donc
possible de vivre ici nous essayons de
restaurer de continuer à vivre
Youri qui vit de l'autre côté de la rue
n'a pas eu cette chance il y a trois
semaines un obus est tombé dans sa cour
les dégâts importants le préoccupe
mais quand sera-t-elle terminée et quand
tout sera-t-il rétabli je n'en sais rien
à deux reprises l'iman a été le théâtre
de violents combats au début de la
guerre lorsque la ville a été envahie
par l'armée russe et à l'automne lors de
sa libération par l'armée ukrainienne
avec des combats qui continuent de faire
rage dans la région du don-basse les
habitants on peut deux raisons d'être
optimiste